>> Tucker: TIME FOR FINAL EXAM
WE BRING TWO PEOPLE WHO MARINATE
IN THE NEWS FOR A LIVING TO FACE
OFF AGAINST ONE ANOTHER TO SEE
WHO IS REALLY PAYING ATTENTION.
ARE YOU READY?
>> I'VE BEEN READING A BOOK ALL
WEEK SPAY
WEEK.
QUESTION THE FIRST ONE TO BUZZ
AND GETS TO ANSWER THE QUESTION
YOU HAVE TO WAIT UNTIL I FINISH
ASKING IN ORDER TO BUZZ.
EACH CORRECT ANSWER IS WORTH ONE
POINT IF YOU GET A QUESTION
WRONG WE DETRACT A POINT, THE
BEST-OF-FIVE WINS.
ARE YOU READY?
WERE ABOUT TO FIND OUT.
NORTH KOREAN DICTATOR
KIM JONG UN HAD A LETTER
HAND-DELIVERED TO THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES.
THERE WAS SOMETHING UNUSUAL
ABOUT THE APPEARANCE OF THIS
LETTER WHAT WAS IT?
WAS THAT SEAN SPICER?
IT'S KATIE!
>> IT WAS VERY LARGE IN
APPEARANCE.
>> Tucker: I DON'T KNOW THE
ANSWER, I'M PLAYING ALONG.
TO THE TAPE WE GO.
>> THIS PLUS SIZED LETTER.
>> THE PRESIDENT ACCEPTING THAT
OVERSIZED MESSAGE FROM
NORTH KOREAN LEADER KIM JONG UN.
>> THE PRESIDENT HOLDING THE
OVERSIZED ENVELOPE.
>> President Trump: I HAVEN'T
OPENED IT.
>> DID THE SECRET SERVICE OPEN
IT, IS WHAT I WANT TO KNOW.
>> Tucker: I DIDN'T KNOW,
IMPRESSIVE.
LIBERALS HAVE DISCOVERED A NEW
ENEMY, THIS WEEK ONE U.S.
SENATOR SLAMMED THAT COMPANY FOR
CORPORATE GREED AND UNDERPAYING
THEMEPARK EMPLOYEES, WAS THAT
POLITICIAN AT BERNIE SANDERS
ELIZABETH WARREN, OR CORY BOOKER
ELIZABETH WARREN, OR CORY BOOKE
CORY BOOKER.
PLAYMATE DISNEY FOR CORPORATE
GREED.
>> ELIZABETH WARREN.
>> Tucker: WAS ELIZABETH
WARREN?
>> YOU TALK ABOUT BEING A FAMILY
ORIENTED COMPANY, WE'VE GOT
FAMILIES RIGHT HERE.
>> Tucker: IN YOUR DEFENSE
THEY ARE KIND OF INTERCHANGEABLE
THEY ARE KIND OF INTERCHANGEABL
INTERCHANGEABLE, BUT NOT
CORRECT.
IF IT'S 0-0 MOVING INTO THE
THIRD QUESTION, HERE IT IS.
AN FBI AGENT FOUND HIMSELF IN
HOT WATER AFTER HE ACCIDENTALLY
FIRED A GUN INTO A CROWD OF BAR
PATRONS AND SHOT SOMEONE.
WHAT WAS HE DOING WHEN HIS GUN
WENT OFF?
>> WE HAVE TO GO TO THE JUDGES.
>> Tucker: YOU HAVE TO WAIT
TILL WE FINISH ANSWERING THE QUE
TILL WE FINISH ANSWERING THE QUT
TILL WE FINISH ANSWERING THE QUO
TILL WE FINISH ANSWERING THE QU
TILL WE FINISH ANSWERING THE QUU
TILL WE FINISH ANSWERING THE QUT
THE JUDGES ARE SAYING THAT'S
OKAY, WITH THE ANSWER?
>> HE WAS DANCING.
>> Tucker: HE WAS DANCING WITH
A GUN I DON'T BELIEVE YOU.
>> AN OFF-DUTY AGENT DANCING THE
NIGHT AWAY UNTIL HIS GUN AND
GETS AWAY, WATCH AS THE AGENT
GOES FOR A BACKFLIP AND HIS
HANDGUN SLIP SLOUGHS, FALLS TO
THE FLOOR AND FIRES.
>> Tucker: IT WAS THE END OF
THE QUESTION ANYWAY YOU GOT IT.
VERY GOOD.
THIS IS A TOUGH ONE I DIDN'T
KNOW THE ANSWER TO THIS.
IHOP INTERNATIONAL HOUSE OF
PANCAKES IS CHANGING ITS NAME
PEOPLE ARE UPSET ABOUT IT, WHAT
IS I HAVE CHANGING NAME TO?
PANCAKES OWN, BREAKFAST PALACE,
IHOB.
>> IHOB.
>> THE INTERNATIONAL HOUSE OF
PANCAKES FLIPPING ITS B4P, I
REFUSED TO CALL IT IHOB YOU
>> Tucker: FOR THE RECORD I
THINK THAT NAME CHANGE WILL MAKE
ALL THE DIFFERENCE.
GOING INTO THE FINAL QUESTION,
IT IS A SUDDEN-DEATH 1-1 HOW
DOES IT ALWAYS WIND UP HERE?
IT'S THE DRAMA INHERENT IN THIS
GAME.
ONE MORE MULTIPLE-CHOICE
QUESTION.
THERE IS AN AMERICAN STATE
TRYING TO GROW ITS POPULATION BY
LITERALLY PAYING PEOPLE TO MOVE
THERE.
$10,000 PER PERSON AS AN
INCENTIVE, HERE ARE THE CHOICES.
IS IT MONTANA, VERMONT, ALASKA.
>> I'M GOING TO GO WITH ALASKA.
>> Tucker: ALASKA SAYS
SEAN SPICER.
IS IT ALASKA?
>> VERMONT WILL PAY $10,000 TO
MOVE THERE.
THEY WILL PAY YOU $10,000 TO
LIVE IN VERMONT AND WORK FROM
HOME, IS THAT IT?
>> Tucker: IT'S A REMOTE
FROZEN STATE FOR THE TIMBER BUTI
FROZEN STATE FOR THE TIMBER BUT'
FROZEN STATE FOR THE TIMBER BUTS
THE WRONG REMOTE FROZEN STATE.
>> IT'S A TIE!
>> Tucker: IS IT?
EVERYONE LOSES TO KATIE SHE'S AN
UNSTOPPABLE FORCE.
DO YOU KATIE GOES THE MEMORIAL
MUG, THAT'S HOW WE FELT ABOUT
THAT.
>> WE NEVER FORGET THIS MOMENT.
>> Tucker: IT WAS A NATIONAL
HOLIDAY ON THIS SHOW.
THANK YOU FOR STOPPING BY.
YOU ARE CRUSHED BY KATIE,
THERE'S NO SHAME IN THAT.